miles de mujeres se reúnen frente al
congreso de la nación argentina en un
día internacional de la mujer y paro
feminista muy especial de este año
porque se da por un lado en el contexto
por supuesto de la pandemia de 2019 pero
también porque ocurre luego de que a
fines de 2020 finalmente el propio
congreso de la nación argentina aprobada
la legalización del aborto que había
sido un reclamo persistente de estos
movimientos pero no el único
demandaban y siguen demandando ahora
equidad en el acceso al empleo equidad
salarial equidad en la distribución de
las tareas de cuidado no remuneradas y
también con mucha fuerza la protección
ante los femicidios en lo que va del año
en argentina se ha dado un femicidio
cada 30 horas aproximadamente siempre ha
similar a la del año 2020 y la exigencia
tiene que ver con pedirle a los
gobiernos nacionales y provinciales ya
las justicias también a nivel nacional y
a nivel provincial que hagan todo lo
necesario para ponerle fin al flagelo de
los femicidios en argentina
[Música]
en este 8 de marzo marcado por la
vendimia en las chilenas no ha querido
dejarme salir a la calle para mostrar su
descontento la coordinadora 8m que en
años anteriores llegó a convocar hasta
más de dos millones de mujeres en las
calles realizó una convocatoria este año
adaptada a los tiempos de kobe con
distintos puntos de encuentro para las
mujeres a lo largo de la alameda la gran
avenida que recorre santiago y también a
distintas horas del día para que muchos
puedan unirse a venir participar gritar
sus consignas volver a irse y otras que
lleguen en su reemplazo muchas de ellas
gritan no estamos todas faltan las
presas las presas de la revuelta y
también las víctimas de femicidio 10 en
lo que van de año en todo el país una
manifestación que deja de manifiesto una
vez más que en chile queda mucho
territorio por recorrer hasta alcanzar
la verdadera igualdad
en el día internacional de la mujer las
mujeres en méjico protestaron en contra
de la violencia que se ejerce en el país
y que le quita la vida por lo menos 10
mujeres en este país en promedio al día
en respuesta el presidente andrés manuel
lópez obrador mandó colocar esas vallas
para evitar que las mujeres realizaran
pintas en los monumentos históricos del
centro de la ciudad de mexico y los
aledaños respuesta las mujeres de la
ciudad de méxico realizaron
intervenciones culturales y artísticas a
lo largo de las vallas para recordar
sobre todo a las mujeres que han sido
asesinadas algunos de los policías de la
ciudad de méxico lograron contener las
manifestaciones sobre todo en el zócalo
de la ciudad a través de gases
lacrimógenos este tipo de
manifestaciones se reprodujeron en los
32 estados de la república en mexico
pero sobre todo a través de las redes
sociales por la pandemia del cob y 19